Você já ouviu falar dessa sigla cifo que
é super crescimento fúngico pessoal é
uma epidemia crescente causada pela
proliferação descontrolada de leveduras
levando a sintomas variados inclusive
gases distensão na barriga o fungo
Cândida albicans é o principal causador
mas outros também podem ser responsáveis
a disbiose fúngica pode estar
relacionada a intoxicação por morfo
doméstico aquele bolor que cresce em
paredes e armários para tratar é
necessário mudar a dieta cortando
açúcares e alimentos refinados e incluir
antifungicos naturais como o caso da
beberina o ácido caprílico o óleo de
orégano o óleo de alho o própolis e a
unha de gato medicamentos antifúngicos
podem ser necessários em doses
individualizadas devido às possíveis
reações adversas é importante consultar
sempre o seu profissional de saúde e
confiança para uma orientação mais
precisa